saved by the bell as you know is
one of my favorite shows i'm the number
one champ of its trivia
regardless of what adonis paul that
cheating
has to say i am
and
one of its look one of the big reasons
the show
the show was big was because of
a screech i mean come on the guy was
like on
every every version of it okay
and um he died
he died of cancer so this is for him
when i wake up in the morning is on a
warning i don't think i'll never make it
on time
and the time i grab my box and i get
myself on look i'm in the corner just in
time to see the bus fly by
it's all right cause i'm safe
if the teacher pops a test you know i
made a mess and my dog get on my
homework last night
i'm here with my channel she won't know
that i'm there if i can handle it
[Music]
right
[Music]
me i want big ass in the chat by the way
for for screech doesn't die i don't care
what anybody says about him
could you at least there's there's a lot
of people see how he feels about this
obviously people that are just posting
that are just posting like oh he was a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] him he's a piece of
[ __ ] i'm glad he died
shut up they're all pieces of [ __ ] all
right everybody was on that [ __ ] show
just dustin diamond was open about it uh
well you look more fatter and creepier
than
terry richardson and flannel oh cool
uh did you hear about georgia publix
boycott no i didn't because i live in
florida
uh yeah so they're all pieces of [ __ ] so
stop pretending like screech was the
only piece of [ __ ]
all right all of them
uh he died of cancer and he died really
quickly like he had cancer that he was
[ __ ] just in a couple weeks gone
um seen mark paul since i was 16.
he hadn't seen mark paul since he was 16
but i think you know
mark paul gosser tweeted something out
like you know he was always the funniest
guy man
he was always the funniest guy dude yeah
it was lung cancer
um so i thought we would show some
things that probably a lot of people
haven't seen
of screech well first off we let me let
me play reliable news source let me
at least show you what you know kind of
little quick recap what happened
hey fellow youtubers welcome to the
dustin tv
um today's video
is about the passing of
dustin diamond
co-star plays
screech on the safe by the bell he
passed away today
at age 44 and he died from
lung stage 4 lung cancer
and dustin and diamond were going to
miss you buddy
and i enjoyed and loved to save by the
bell and
we're all going to miss you and i know
you're going to be up there with god
and jesus and everybody else
up there in heaven we're going to miss
you dustin diamond
well guys it is cold oh my god
someone pointed this out and now this is
all i could see
dustin looks like if even though ag luck
and jj were fighting yesterday
it looks like they fused together as one
person
dustin tv is if jj stoner and aj luck
would win a cloning accident and became
one person
like that episode of voyager with a
tuvak and uh what's his face
nelix that's
wow that's all i could see now holy [ __ ]
look seriously
that's all i could see now you guys just
merged together into one person
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] oh no
it's two fix
it's a.g stoner it's jj
luck
oh [ __ ] man holy [ __ ]
all right look i was talking about save
mother i was talking about screech okay
but wait wait wait wait wait let me
finish the video hold on finish the
video because that's all i want to say
here i'm
in my old navy jacket
and i am wearing a
light denim skirt long one too
i get he's wearing a long denim skirt
well done sir sorry for the bad fat joke
whole nature pretty quick
you know cold
i'm already shaking though but
this is the way it looks out here
yeah my four-wheeler is out of
commission it don't want to shift
but we gotta wear it we'll crank up now
but what does that do with dustin i just
wanted to get on here and
and tell y'all about dustin
diamond passing i knew he had
stage four long lung cancer
but i didn't know he was gonna die this
quick
i thought i was going to help him try to
get rid of the cancer
but i guess if it's a stage 4
i guess there's nothing they can do
damn it's cold out here jesus christ
i can't believe it's february the month
of my birthday
february 18th happy birthday happy early
birthday
dustin diamond buddy you got
i when i watched your here we go finally
eulogy your tv show of
safe by the bell i never thought your
name was
the same name as mine dustin
dude they're like the same guy
damn it's cold oh yeah jesus christ
i kind of liked us to tv to be honest
with you
as far as annoying people on the
internet i mean i look i'm sure he's
annoying and he has his things but
he's not worse than [ __ ] dayton
nobody's worse than dating hypernova
i'm going to get out here for a minute
but
dustin diamond
god bless you and and everybody's
on this earth that watch you're safe by
the bell
they're gonna miss you buddy and we love
you
and we'll see you really soon dustin
diamond
god bless you whoa how soon way hey hey
hey
does he know something i don't know like
how soon are we gonna see him
all right because for me we're gonna see
him right now we're gonna see him right
now
here you go
[Applause]
dustin gets state minimum coverage with
insurance king
he saved so much on car insurance that
now he's going for a minimum coverage
wardrobe
he can you punk get covered i am covered
barely when it comes to minimum coverage
stick to insurance insurance king drive
legal for less
huh huh
do you realize it's illegal to screech
your tires yeah but it's kind of my
thing
just trying to do the screech voice hey
thanks
how can you afford car insurance with
that many tickets come on i'm saved by
the king
get it insurance kick
drive legal for less i'm dustin diamond
and if you're loving these insurance
king videos
do the right thing hit like and
subscribe because that makes us say
thanks he's still
he was still trying to do the screech
voice there
he was still trying to do the screech
voice there
that's right legends never die
see you in the big bayside in the sky
poor screech
he did a lot of because he did he did
the sex tape which whatever he
did a sex tape he released one he
stabbed somebody in a bar that guy was
being a dick um
he wrote that tell-all book look i guess
it's kind of the book thing was kind of
shitty i will agree
but also they did treat him like [ __ ]
garbage
like if you talk about some of the [ __ ]
they did to him on the set like
they [ __ ] with him really hard like he
wasn't just a nerd on the show
they made him a [ __ ] nerd in in like
real life they [ __ ] with him i'm not
saying that that forgives everything he
did but
um still kind of [ __ ]